the only thing i've managed to change
in the last two days is i thought that
the rather crass title of piers is pack
i thought it was lazy so yesterday we
renamed it jezza's journals and joining
me now on day two this is going to be
hard work so
hold on a minute
listen be quiet i haven't even started
socialist author known to like champagne
grace blakely it doesn't work a marxist
moe drinker don't give me that and talk
tv contributor esther crackers or craico
is what they call of course how are we
great um they said to me um there's so
many things that we want to talk about
but but what we should start with is
well i'll tell you what we'll leave that
to the end cost of living you heard me
say bp 6.9 billion quid profit in the
last three months three times last year
whilst this country quite literally is
on its backside bill's going through the
roof 3600 quid in january short sharp
answers is it not disgraceful that these
companies are not being forced to give
back some profit this here's my problem
because i do think it's disgraceful when
they're clearly profiting off giving
people a hard time when they're finding
it difficult to live i fundamentally
disagree with the windfall tax in
principle because it's it's the
government saying oh we think you've
made a bit too much money this year so
we're just going to take it back but
what i do think they should be doing is
making these big corporations pay pay
their fair share in the first place yeah
right you shouldn't need a win for tax
if companies like amazon like bp like
these massive companies are actually
paying what they should be paying in the
first place now well we we would be
politically very apart but colonel bob
stewart tory mp said i'm gonna sound
socious it is immoral that these
companies are making this money when
people in this country are struggling
right it's immoral it's irrational it
makes absolutely no sense where is all
this money going there's all this money
is going into the pockets of legislation
well this is the point right the reason
that we've had all these long-term cuts
to corporation tax is that we were told
we'll cut corporation tax and nice
responsible companies will go out and
spend it on investment create jobs boost
wages we've had a decade of wage
stagnation right uh at least in part
because we've had this long-term attack
on the labor movement people haven't
been able to bargain for higher wages
and what these fossil fuel companies
done they have not invested in what they
said they would do which is
decarbonizing finding alternative
sources of energy instead they've just
raked it in on fossil fuels exacerbating
the climate crisis and also examination
jeremy carl's just become a marxist
she's speaking complete sense isn't she
a woman i know for the first time right
oh don't start right
i am told to move you lot along because
we've got lots to get through penny
morton it was like that with liz trust
they were slagging each other off has
now come in support of her out last
night introduced at the the exeter
hosting it was like somebody said it was
the best uh speech it sounded oscar like
she was prepared she's been angling for
a job in the cabin hasn't she graced
well i mean this is so unsurprising this
is what politicians do you know they are
machines that are programmed to ensure
their own self-interest to maximize
their own interests and penny morden's
decided that she's going to fall in line
behind liz trust because it's very
obvious at this point that liz trust is
going to win it's why our political
system is so broken it's why it took so
long for boris johnson to be ousted
because everyone you know elsewhere are
you gutted about that are you what about
boris johnson yeah absolutely i think i
think he'll be back in two years do you
know what my conspiracy
i think liz trust will serve for 10
right this is true i read this today
let's trust himself for two years she'll
make him the ukrainian envoy to keep him
in the spotlight she will end up not
winning the next general election it'll
be a bit of a stage situation stamina
will get with the
i think rolling back completely the
tories majority would be quite hard
because it's quite significant
i think it'll be a slight lead i think
it will be a slightly done the only
reason why i say that is because this is
an excellent opportunity for kirsten to
really be sort of surging boring but but
the label the labour party's in fights
the conservative party literally don't
have a leader right now and labor is
basically neck and neck with yeah so the
labour party should be out because
you're so right chris they should be out
there
so
many things right now that are going on
that the labour party should be out
there talking about saying we are on
your side we are here to protect your
interests
you know what happened at sam terry on
the picket line angela rainer's
boyfriend he didn't like me saying that
the other day but the truth is they're
going to tear themselves apart politics
in this country is is on the precipice
now i was told if i mention this i have
to move my chair back
600 migrants arrive today
we've got to stop them haven't we
yesterday
yeah that's right
he's waiting for us to tear up
this is the thing i i feel like because
we always thought about the amount of
money that we're spending keeping these
migrants in a hotel and all of that and
i just said if you look at it from the
french perspective they really don't
have much of an incentive to keep the
migrants on french shores for instance
there's a war isn't that that's why
they're coming here because it's a
warned oh no france isn't water that's
that's the thing but i think the bigger
argument is
actually being able to turn them back
right because it's not just about keep
because once they land on british shores
that's the end you need to turn them
back not just for the sake of the money
wasn't it for the industry wasn't it
literally just a few weeks ago that we
were having a big existential crisis in
this country because the birth rate is
too low because we can't get workers to
work in the nhs these people this is
actually the big problem that we have in
this country is that there aren't enough
people this is brexit well i mean
migration has gone down so
no way
i'm gonna jump straight in i don't think
that's right at all well it is no no
i'll tell you what's wrong is
unfortunately we have we i always
thought the benefit system and the
welfare state was the greatest invention
in the modern world i really
passionately believe this i am very
happy to pay whatever to help people who
can't help themselves but the fact of
the matter is nowadays in this country
you can go to work you can go to college
you can choose to go on the doll there
are millions you can't choose there are
people who do not choose to go to work
because the benefit system has made it
as easy for them it's a fact whether you
like it or not they should be made to do
that narrative is completely unhinged
from reality it's completely it's like
over the last 15 years it's become
extremely difficult to go in and claim
these about universal credit there have
been people who've been found in their
houses i don't disagree with that but
there are yeah
yeah
they have been keen live because they
haven't shown up for a job center
appointment because they've had funerals
grace you can talk there are people who
choose to be on the dole because they
know that they might earn 20 quid more
to go to work and you can argue all the
day i agree with what you've said it's
crazy that you could be on the dole and
earning barely more than you would be i
agree but i'm telling you now partly
because you know have you seen normal
ways
the issue is that we are not supporting
the labor movement we're not supporting
workers to go out and bargain for higher
wages but secondly they're always going
to be people in our society who require
help who require support disabled people
because you can't work at the point and
this is you know we should not be but do
you not keep punching down do you not
want the money hear me out then let's
try a different tack the help that we
should genuinely give to the people that
you've just mentioned
we shouldn't be giving it to migrants
should we
well again migrants come over here this
is the classic thing of like migrants
are simultaneously coming over here and
sitting on benefits and also coming over
here and taking all our jobs actually
most people who come over here do tend
to find jobs often in the nhs there's so
many people in our social okay okay
people who are looking after them
all coming off the boat are not working
for the nhs they don't maybe if they're
refugees they're not refugees
we don't know where they're coming from
we don't know their history these people
are p they're p they're being trafficked
by people smugglers this is an industry
but that's actually not a gross
generalization
why is it why is it at any point why is
it that any point that you don't agree
with you say is a gross you know
generalization generalization
there are people who come to this
country who tear up their brains
but like i'm telling you this for a fact
and i know this because personally i
know someone who made this trip over the
mediterranean one minute ladies i've got
a headache he actually went to italy but
i know people like this there is for
every migrant you see coming off those
boats there are people that have died in
the mediterranean or on the channel
trying to come here and they're
profiting the people that are profiting
off their deaths are people's money
risking their lives risking a huge
amount to come here work for our nhs
support
hey jess's journals chill chill chill
the champagne's coming out let's agree
to disagree don't worry about talking to
me here i've got this don't worry don't
worry i'm on it don't worry just i've
got a clock chill what an honor esther
crackers has been taken on by grace
buddy i loved that that was fantastic
thank you so much
for the love
you prefer jesus journalists to pierce
his pack right they're both awful really
you